well days after the taliban insurgency
completed its takeover of kabul the
militia is now trying to convince
afghans that life can return to normal
there are of course very big questions
remaining among them how the group will
finance a government
more on that in a moment let's look
first at how it funded an insurgency
between 300 million and 1.6 billion
dollars a year that's a pretty big range
and that's how much the taliban are
estimated to have earned every year as
an insurgency now a large part of that
as most of you have probably heard has
come from the opium trade opium used to
make illegal drugs like heroin
now drug harvest are believed to have
hit 460 million dollars for the taliban
last year
but in recent years illegal mines have
become a growing source of revenue when
recent estimate by the u.n put last
year's take at a whopping 464 million
dollars
now afghan afghanistan is in fact
sitting on a wealth of untapped minerals
the country has vast reserves of lithium
uranium rare earths chromite gold zinc
natural gas and even oil total value
estimated at over three trillion dollars
now the question now is whether a
governing taliban can exploit that
wealth something that past governments
have been unable to do
now for more on this i'm joined now by
hans jacob schindler he's senior
director of the counter extremism
project and he was formerly part of that
taliban monitoring team at the unhans
thank you for joining us first of all um
you know we've touched on this just a
moment ago funding a government
is very different from funding an
insurgency what will be the biggest
challenges facing the taliban assuming
that they in fact want to govern this
entire country
good morning and thank you so much for
having me um obviously as you pointed
out there is a big difference
and the taliban have never really
governed the country these resources
that you refer to were on the ground in
the 90s as well and they never were able
to extract them so one has to remain
very critical of the ability to actually
grow the afghan economy or even their
interest in doing so so obviously
apart from the drugs and the illegal
mining and the extortion business which
was extremely well organized until now
they now are in charge of a country
whose economy is either a drug economy
and don't forget the taliban did not
cooperate or co-opt the drug trade in
order to fight the insurgency they were
born out of the drug trade when we
looked at their finances at the u.n from
the very beginning their finances was
via drug lords so in a way i doubt uh
their announcement yesterday very much
that they want to eradicate drug
production in afghanistan and their
ability to do so because the commanders
on the ground basically have no other
income source and
this country and its economy is highly
dependent on foreign aid and that will
not change either
speaking that foreign aid we've heard
already the us is stopping its cash
deliveries to kabul now what about the
central bank reserves that were already
there in the country as the taliban has
swept across have they gained access to
reserves and to money that they can then
employ in their governing
naturally but i mean no reserves in the
country it was a big windfall for the
group are enough to run in a country uh
the country in a sustainable manner
there's not that much cash if you think
about uh on a national scale so they
will depend on outside help and that's
why they are now talking about uh the
quote-unquote inclusive government
there's rumors that mr kazai mr abdullah
abdullah
the ones who were in the negotiating
team may have some role in this new
government this is not because the
taliban have a newfound
sense of democratic inclusivity um this
is an attempt to actually make sure that
this international money keeps flowing
at least from some
there's also a a a large amount of imf
reserves especially slated for
afghanistan the taliban are now ruling
afghanistan will they have access to
those reserves
um theoretically yes but i mean don't
forget there is not only a united
nations security council sanctions
regime which
includes many of the taliban leaders who
are now in control in afghanistan and a
absolute and total global asset freeze
but they're also a host of bilateral
sanctions from the eu against
individuals but also most significantly
from the u.s so yes
potentially the new government will have
access to those resources
in practical operational terms i highly
doubt that they can access them and
transfer them to afghanistan we touched
on mining earlier is there any is it
believable at all that they will be able
to get the commercial exploitation of
these mines up and running in any time
well i mean these resources are on the
ground and there is absolutely very
little infrastructure to get them out at
scale i mean one of the main problems at
the until the current time was that you
were not able to get the resources out
of the country because you would need as
a company and need a private army to
secure them against the taliban now that
threat of course has gone um but the
infrastructure which was not built
because of this commercial problem um is
still not there so they would need
large-scale investment and i know
chinese companies have secured
large-scale mining concessions in
afghanistan but there's still no
infrastructure to do so
all right and all of this of course
assuming that the fighting is indeed
over hans jakob schindler with the
counter extremism project thank you very
much
thank you
you